that's all on me i got to be better at
taking care of the ball and uh
just doing a better job of just uh at
least getting us a shot and uh
non-tournament is way too much and i got
to do better and i will be better next
game so
uh definitely a big reason they didn't
do nothing uh too much different they
just
just played more aggressive this was
just uh
it's more aggressive and uh it's gotten
them a lot more
to to go tonight so um just got to be
better and
just be be able to respond a lot better
did it feel like one of those nights
where it just wasn't the team's night
and
it was just going to be one of those
nights where you guys get blown out for
sure for sure
especially as the game continued we knew
how desperate they needed this one
so as as the game went on i
felt like they were hitting everything
and we just we couldn't get a shot to
drop and it was just
one of those nights and sometimes it
happens like that it sucks it happened
tonight but
we got to be able to bounce back